Hello, and welcome back.
So, in our last lesson, we added
this lovely view leaderboards
controller that
doesn't show anything,
because we have no leaderboards.
So let's think
about adding some.
Now, we have three difficulty
levels in our game,
easy, medium and hard.
Probably makes sense for each
one have its own leaderboard.
So let's go ahead and do that.
I'm going to pop over to Chrome
here, and trick this a bit.
And I'm going to go to
play.google.com/apps/publish,
the developer console, and
check out our game services.
And let's go in to
Guess My Number.
So we can go into
a leaderboards.
and the process here is fairly
similar to adding achievements.
We fill out all the
various information
that we need in a form.
And then the system
generates a unique ID for us
that we can use later to
refer to this leaderboard.
So let's do that.
I'm going to click
on Add Leaderboard.
And for this one, our
name is going to be Easy.
And this will be the leaderboard
for an easy difficulty level.
We have some options
for score formatting.
It can be numeric,
which would be
like an integer, or
a floating point.
We also have options
for currency and time.
And maybe if we
wanted to do a fastest
time to guess the answer
type of leaderboard,
we can use time for that.
We have an icon.
This is optional.
I do recommend using icons
if you want to create, say,
actual games that you want
people to download and buy.
The reason is that in the Play
Game standalone application,
your leaderboard icons do
show up fairly prominently.
Someone looks at your game,
one of the three screens
that they're going to
see about your game
are going to be
your leaderboards.
And in those cases, it's
nice to have leaderboard
icons that look interesting.
In our case, we're going
to stick with the default
leaderboard icon, as provided
by Play Game Services, which
is like a little crown thing.
Ordering here, we can
choose whether larger
is better, or smaller is better.
In this case, our
leaderboard is going
to be based on the
number of guesses.
So how many guesses did it
take to get the magic number?
So in this case,
smaller is better.
I do want to take
a moment to add,
this is my favorite feature
of this developer console.
Rather than having
ascending or descending,
and then you have to
stop and think, well
what does that actually mean?
Like, smaller is better.
So much clearer.
Love it.
Anyway, then we have limits,
and these are basically
the upper and lower
bounds of any score that
gets submitted to
this leaderboard.
So I suppose we want
to say that we don't
want to allow scores
lower than one.
Makes sense.
You can't actually make
a guess in zero guesses.
And maybe for the small
leaderboard, we want to say,
you know what, let's not
allow scores greater than 100.
In theory, someone could
make the same wrong guess
over and over and
over and over again,
and maybe our players
are going to have
some fun, perverse, hey, let's
see who can get the worst
score in our Guess Our
Number game contest.
Maybe that's something you
want to encourage your players
to do, but in my case,
I'm going to say, no,
let's not encourage
that behavior.
We're just going to cap
our lower bounds, or, I
guess our upper
bounds here, at 100.
And list order means
that if you were
to view your leaderboards, where
would this appear on the list?
And we'll have it appear first.
So there we go, this is done.
I'm going to hit Save and
add another leaderboard.
We'll create another
one for medium.
This should be pretty easy.
Smaller is better, and let's
allow scores of 1 and 1,000.
Save and add
another leaderboard,
and hard, smaller is
better, and 1 and 10,000.
Let's save.
And we're done, look at that.
We've got three leaderboards.
We have unique IDs associated
with each one of them.
And they should be
ready to publish.
We've actually
done everything we
need to do to get a
leaderboard into our game.
So let's go back to our
application and try it out.
If I were to hit leaderboards
right now, I'd probably-- yeah,
I'd get the cached version.
So one quick way
to fix this would
be to sign out and sign back in,
or you could just stop, and run
our application again.
And now it'll kind
of force our game
to go out and grab
the latest data.
So now when I
click leaderboards,
I now have three entries,
easy, medium and hard.
Now, if I were to
click on this easy one,
I'm taken to my individual
leaderboard, where
I can see entries for
public submissions
this leaderboard, and
anybody from my circles
that has submitted a
score to this leaderboard.
In this case, this is a
brand new leaderboard,
nobody has submitted anything,
so all these entries are blank.
That's kind of too bad
and kind of boring.
But that's OK because
in the next lesson,
we'll start submitting
scores to these leaderboards.
So stay tuned, and
I'll see you soon.